you all know Taylor Swift is having a
massive year um her aist tour is
expected to bring in 3.6 billion and
this visualization behind me was made in
R so you can actually make this yourself
with code I didn't make this my coworker
Isabella did but she's going to show you
how you can make this too in CA in R you
can create a tree map using ggplot 2 in
the tree mapify package first you have
to convert your data frame into the
right format to visualize those
relationships using the tree mapify
function which I do here next I
initialize the gigg plot two that I want
to
create then I add my tree
map I can even add a custom image if I
want
to finally I finished adding all the
details to the gig plot that I want and
when I use gig save it's going to save
this image